Ce samedi sur RFI éco
d'ailleurs, Bruno Four.
Inflation et Vichère, la colère
sociale gronde dans de nombreux
pays, notamment en Afrique. Où
en sont les syndicats qui
défendent les droits et les
intérêts des travailleurs des
citoyens plus généralement?
Quels sont leurs relations avec
le pouvoir politique et avec
les grandes entreprises
multinationales? Écodissieurs
avec la BOAD. Tous les samedis
à dix heures dix TU sur RFI.
Défi et France 24 présentent
Radio FOOT International, le
CAF des sports, Annie Gasnier
Bonjour à tous et merci d'être
au rendez-vous du CAF des
sports juste avant votre
week-end nous sommes là pour
euh, animer votre fin de
journée et euh, un salut
particulier à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent au Burkina Faso
euh, on a perdu les
téléspectateurs mais j'espère
que ils pourront euh, continuer
à nous suivre que ce soit à
travers la radio ou à travers
Internet euh, grâce à Facebook.
Facebook Live bien sûr. Alors,
dans ce studio notre trio est
là toujours fidèle au
rendez-vous bonjour Rémy Ngono
bonjour Annie et bonjour à
toutes les téléspectatrices et
surtout j'ai apprécié la veste
des a tout de suite là j'ai
félicité
oui bonjour Annie merci je vais
rougir bonjour à tous. Ah non
mais c'est allusion à nos
débats. Bonjour euh Frédéric
bonjour Annie bonjour tout le
monde, les auditeurs le
Facebook live vous en parliez
c'est parti euh à Kinshasa
bonjour la famille euh de Radio
Foot du CAF des sports je vous
suis donc depuis Khed heureux
de vous écouter c'est parti. Eh
ben on est heureux qu'il soit
là et qu'il euh soit euh en
ligne pour donner son avis
puisque euh Frédéric vous êtes
aussi chargé de jeter un oeil
aux réactions de nos auditeurs
internautes et l'invité du
jour, il s'appelle Eric
Rabesandratana bonjour. Bonjour
Annie, bonjour à tous. Pas trop
triste? Triste de? Bah les
Barret vont pas très très fort
on va dire. Ben rappeler Éric.
Bah ouais non mais ça
m'intéresse après il faut un
vrai projet parce que je je
repartirai pas à l'aventure
comme je suis parti à
l'aventure la première fois
mais ouais avec un vrai projet
et des des des vrais choix euh.
Emmener des barrières à une
canne c'est quand même
intéressant. Ouais et je suis
sûr et certain qu'il y a le
potentiel maintenant faut tout
mettre en place pour euh sur
sur deux de allez on va dire
sur 5 ans vous arrive vous
arriverez à faire euh de belles
choses, je suis sûre. Il y a
plus de petites équipes euh il
y a que de de de une vraie
organisation et Madagascar est
allée à la CAN déjà. Vous
regardez Aliou Cissé, ils sont
là depuis euh voilà, Belmadi 5
ans, Alice et 8 ans et les deux
ont gagné la CAN je dis pas que
Madagascar peut gagner la CAN,
je dis simplement que on peut
mettre des projets en place au
sommaire des débats du jour euh
nous évoquerons la reprise des
championnats, et oui la pause
internationale est
terminé et pour certains
championnats ça commence sur
les chapeaux de roues en
Allemagne, baptême du feu pour
Thomas Tuchel premier match sur
le banc du Bayern Munich pour
un classiqueur qui s'annonce
très chaud. Le Brussia Dortmund
est en premier au classement,
alors qu'en Angleterre, la
bataille du Big Four conserve
tout son suspense, tout son
sel, les Reds n'ont peut-être
pas dit leur dernier mot. Le
football féminin français sur
une mauvaise pente, les
tenantes du titre et les
Parisiennes éliminées de la
ligue des championnes hier soir
au moment où le nouveau
sélectionneur des Bleues Bleues
avec un E affiche ses ambitions
pour le mondial et pour les
Jeux Olympiques bonne chance
Hervé Renard le Bénin à la
peine dans les éliminatoires
pour la CAN deux-0-vingt-quatre
mais le pays des néo-guers
est-il lésé une fois encore par
d'étranges décisions de la CAF
les Béninois vont-ils sortir
leurs griffes au générique de
cette émission, Pierre Guérin
m'a aidé à préparer l'émission
avec euh Victor Alice est à la
réalisation avec Souheil Khedir
et Yann Bourdelas pour les
moyens vidéos. Et puis un salut
aujourd'hui un peu particulier,
Alexandra notre préfet. Ça fait
exactement un mois, un an un
mois qui un an qui me défiait
décidément. C'était il y a pas
longtemps. Un an qu'ils
profitent euh gaiement de sa
retraite. De de sa retraite
mais euh il nous manque
champion du monde dans
l'intervalle et le studio lui
reste ouvert. Le CAF des
sports, les débats sont
ouverts.
Buck, heat, sleep, Loopit,
Rythme de travail soutenu donc
pour Thomas Tuchel le nouvel
entraîneur du Bayern Munich.
Après 6 mois sans entraîner,
alors lui qui a érigé cent
matchs exactement avec euh
Chelsea avant d'être euh
remercié, eh bien il se
retrouve à la tête des ogres
bavarois. Alors un Bayern qui
vient d'aligner dix titres de
champion d'Allemagne et qui ne
voudrait pas perdre le onzième.
C'est pour ça qu'on a renvoyé à
ses chères études et qu'on a
appelé Thom il a été appelé en
sauveur un peu comme à Chelsea
d'ailleurs euh Thomas euh
Tuchel là il est en terrain euh
connu ou presque, lui
l'Allemand qui retrouve la
Bundesliga. Euh il se retrouve
en plus pour une vingt-sixième
journée un peu importante
puisque c'est le classiqueur et
que juste avant la pose, le
Bayern est descendu d'un cran,
il est deuxième derrière le
BVB. Thomas Tuchel a-t-il euh
une euh baguette magique? En
tout cas, écoutez le travail
euh qu'il a euh euh à ses à ses
troupes, vous avez entendu tout
à l'heure, il a dit work it euh
sleep and a gain, c'est-à-dire
euh on bosse à 00 %. Euh Thomas
Tuchel il a une baguette
magique euh à la place de de
Nagolsman euh. Ben on avait
Xavier dans l'émission pourquoi
avait été écartée, c'était pas
seulement pour les résultats,
c'était aussi pour euh parce
qu'il y avait une euh des
problèmes relationnels,
notamment avec certains cadres,
à commencer par euh Manuel
Newer qui euh euh n'avait pas
du tout apprécié la mise à
l'écart de de l'entraîneur des
gardiens, qui serait selon euh
euh selon euh qui auraient qui
soit selon Nagal Smann, celui
qui va lancer les infos à la
presse. Bref, bref euh les les
listes euh apparues euh dans la
presse euh mettent plus de de
d'internationaux en tout cas en
cause mais c'était pas le seul
hein. Voilà donc du coup on
prend Tuchel mais ça c'était
une euh vieille idée des
dirigeants du Bayern depuis
longtemps puisque ils avaient
voulu prendre Tourelle mais le
PSG à l'époque avait été plus
rapide qu'eux. Donc il vient,
c'est finalement quelque part
une euh un retour logique, la
seule chose, c'est les
circonstances qui sont
particulières, puisqu'il arrive
comme vous l'avez Annie en
plein milieu de saison, voire
même plutôt vers la fin de
saison euh dans un club un peu
en crise qui fait qu'il a pas
pu préparer euh euh
l'avant-saison ou même la trêve
comme euh comme on le fait
d'habitude. Mais euh il a déjà
connu ça à Chelsea et ça s'est
très bien passé puisqu'ils ont
gagné la Ligue des champions au
bout. Donc je pense que son
expérience aujourd'hui des
champions qu'on l'attend là,
c'est sur le le championnat je
pense. Non mais si si le Bayern
n'est pas champion mais qu'il
gagne la Ligue des champions,
Tuchel aura réussi son arrivée
hein. Ouais peut-être. Éric.
Non, après je pense que c'est
quand même l'homme de la
situation pour le mettre
maintenant, c'est-à-dire que
quand vous changez d'entraîneur
ou à l'intersaison,
c'est-à-dire en en hiver, euh
là euh en plein milieu comme ça
là, c'est très compliqué pour
un entraîneur d'arriver, mais
il est allemand, il connaît
très bien le championnat, il
connaît très bien le Bayern, il
connaît très bien Dortmund donc
les les conditions pour lui
pour commencer avec euh avec le
Bayern sont plus faciles
maintenant euh voilà, je sais
pas comment il il est perçu par
rapport au au groupe euh de de
de
Munich mais euh voilà je pense
que c'est quand même l'homme de
la situation pour le Bayern
pour l'instant. Rémy selon
vous, qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
de mieux Thomas Tuchel en étant
à la tête de ce Bayern Munich?
Est-ce que euh il a il va
travailler très différemment de
on on connaît son style de jeu,
je crois que c'est pas tout à
fait le style de de Tuchel donc
euh qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
avec évidemment le même
effectif? Première des choses
euh il faut déjà savoir que ce
n'est pas très différent. parce
que travailler déjà aussi avec
la défense à trois. Ce qui est
aussi sa particularité, que ce
soit avec Chelsea, donc ça ne
sera pas une désorganisation
complète, d'autant plus qu'il
peut s'appuyer pas mécano, sur
les pavardes, sur les délais
voilà. Il va retrouver Achille
euh Choupo Poutine. Euh Maxime
Tchoupoting. Il va retrouver
justement aussi des élus qui
sont performants. Donc il n'a
pas besoin de renforcer son son
effectif parce que à part euh
le gardien de but tout
l'effectif est là. Et
maintenant lorsque vous essayez
de faire de plus, il a
commencé, c'est-à-dire le
travail. Oui. Vous savez que le
travail le le travail au niveau
du Bayern c'est-à-dire que le
travail foncier est très
important et ça il a fait et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il le fait
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
qu'il vienne? Parce que
justement n'avait pas ces
méthodes de travail aussi
rigoureuses aussi ceci et cela
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
vous avez constaté qu'en 2013
eh bien papa était parti en
retraite. Après avoir mis le
Bayern au sommet c'est-à-dire
mais il est revenu en
deuxmilledix8. Pourquoi? Parce
que le Bayern justement se
retrouvait dans la même
position avec Carlo Ancelotti
qui justement ne s'entendait
pas avec certains cadres comme
et justement le Bayern était à
cinq point de retard de
Dortmund le Bayern venait
d'être battu au mois de
septembre. Oui oui le Bayern
venait d'être battu par Paris
Saint-Germain trois buts
d'avril. Mais mais
pas en début
pour te dire que aucun rapport
par rapport à cet effectif-là
et par rapport au fait que on a
pu voir qu'il a redressé ce
Bayern de Munich là qui
d'ailleurs avait remporté euh
le championnat. Donc quand on
fait venir un entraîneur qui a
ce rythme de travail eh bien
moi je ne vois pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'il échouerait.
D'accord. Euh Fred tuto une
chose c'est que quand même
cette équipe euh hum de
Dortmund en face elle est elle
a pris la première place, elle
n'a pas perdu en 2023 et c'est
quand même une équipe euh
difficile euh pour euh le
Bayern les 10 derniers matchs
de championnat c'est on c'est
neuf victoires, un nul je crois
depuis début novembre, même si
on a eu la la coupe du monde
entre temps, euh Dortmund n'a
n'a pas perdu, euh il y a Jude
Bellingham qui qui est là,
l'année dernière il y avait
Erling à Londres euh on se
disait qu'avec le départ euh
Dalland a a euh Dortmund allait
rentrer dans le rang et
l'équipe est meilleure euh
c'est c'est un match qui risque
d'être compliqué mais pour
revenir ce que sur ce que
disait nos nos consultants hum
il arrive on elle est elle est
inattendue quand même cette
arrivée de Thomas Tuchel en
tout cas le le limogeage de
timing ouais. Le timing euh
c'est plutôt des des histoires
internes parce que l'équipe
elle tournait bien euh elle a
éliminé le PSG en 8e de finale,
certes Dortmund est passé
devant mais sportivement
parlant, il y a pas une crise
de de je crois donc en plus euh
c'est jusqu'à la
trente-quatrième, on est la
vingt-sixième donc c'est c'est
vraiment la fin de saison
certes ils viennent de perdre
d'un point euh du championnat
mais mais il y a il y a je
trouve qu'il y a quand même une
tendance qui se dégage de cette
équipe de de de du Bayern c'est
que moi aujourd'hui si je
regarde le parcours qu'ils ont
fait et ce qu'ils dégagent en
termes de jeu et de je me je me
dis pas ils vont gagner euh
largement le championnat, je me
dis pas ils vont gagner la
Ligue des champions donc
aujourd'hui ils sont quand même
dans une dans une phase où ils
sont pas séduisants euh si en
plus il y a des problème il y
avait des problèmes internes
avec l'entraîneur euh je je
peux comprendre la démarche,
maintenant ça veut pas dire que
mais je je suis pas sûr, je
suis pas sûr que avec euh il
serait allé au bout des deux
euh je pense pas hein Citizens
en plus a été éliminé de la
Ligue des champions, donc eux
ils ont plus que le championnat
à jouer et ça c'est important.
au Bayern eux ils n'ont plus la
la Ligue des champions et donc
euh ça peut leur apporter.
Quelques messages? Allez. Bah
oui. Technique qui nous dit euh
il peut gagner Thomas Tuchel,
la Bundesliga et la Ligue des
champions, c'est un entraîneur
chanceux partout où il passe
euh on va voir si ça se
confirme mais c'est vrai que
peut-être pas au PSG récupéré
Chelsea Comme il voulait aussi.
Et puis le pronostic de de
Doumbia on le voit derrière
nous, il avait gagné la la la
coupe euh d'Allemagne avec euh
le classique keller, le
classique c'est déjà fini.
C'est ça. Victoire trois un
pour le Bayern face à Dortmund
Pronostic donc de de Doumbia
Karam. En tout cas, il joue à
la Bayern Arena et c'est vrai
que ça peut être un avantage
toujours d'être devant son
public à Munich. En Angleterre,
la bataille pour décrocher une
place dans le Big Four est
relance à la garde tout son
suspens hein par rapport à
avant la pause avec une
inconnue euh bon alors là il
est dans le Big Four il est
quatrième d'ailleurs, c'est le
club de Tottenham qui est
toujours sans entraîneur. Une
chance peut-être en tout cas
pour d'autres de se frayer un
chemin dans ce groupe où on
veut euh une place pour euh
jouer la Ligue des champions de
la saison d'après. Il y aura
deux matchs importants au cours
du week-end, derrière Arsenal,
toujours leader isolé et qui
reçoit Leed United, les
Citizens sans Phil FOOT
peut-être sans euh Hallande qui
est incertain, reçoivent
Liverpool, De Reds qui sont
encore sixièmes, qui ont deux
matchs de retard, donc c'est
toujours un peu difficile
d'avoir une vision, mais euh
est-ce que vous voyez, Rémy
? Alors euh peut-être au terme
de ce match, peut-être pas, les
Reds revenir dans le Big Four
anglais? Ça serait difficile?
Difficile parce que en même
temps euh ils sont ils sont
irrégul ils sont ils sont
irréguliers, ils ont aussi des
blessés importants hein, parce
que là on va vous dire que
c'est Firmino qui revient comme
attaquant de pointe, ils n'ont
pas niais, ils n'ont pas de
diaze sans pour autant oublier
que Gaspou n'est pas là et au
milieu de terrain il manque
quand même Alcantara et quand
vous essayez de voir euh les
qui sont là Liverpool cette
saison. Donc on se dit quand
même que ce sera très très
difficile par rapport à une
équipe de Munich qui bah pas de
Munich par une équipe de Citiz
qui a tout son potentiel, qui a
des joueurs qui bien
ne devrait pas se retrouver là
parce que si c'était un autre
entraîneur je crois qu'on
l'aurait déjà licencié.
Guardiola par rapport à ce
qu'il y a. Oui oui oui c'est
vrai. Mais mais malheureusement
parce que avec autant d'argent
quart de finale de la CAN où il
est mais jusqu'à présent quand
même. Il n'y a pas grand chose
au niveau des Citiz donc pour
moi pour moi huit point de
retard sur Arsenal, je dis bien
que Guardiola déjà d'être
évincé
ou bien s'il ne plante pas les
3 point le chasser il ne sert à
rien à city mais
malheureusement on va rester là
parce qu'il y a un problème
africain qui dit on est jamais
quelqu'un qui a une ****
attachée à son cou. Euh bon
Éric
c'était drôle là où je le
rejoins pour Guardiola c'est
que si on est on est sur les
attentes de la Ligue des
champions c'est vrai que ça me
ferait un moment qu'il aurait
dû être euh viré par rapport à
ça mais comme il fait tellement
de choses bien sûr, c'est pour
ça que je dis que et Rémy
Champion hein. Et puis plus
rien, il a tout gâté. C'est Il
a été champion quatre fois sur
cinq euh il y a pas de match
entre ces deux équipes. Entre
Citizens et et Liverpool? À ce
stade euh il y a il y a Il y a
un enjeu pour Liverpool mais
euh il y a il y a United, il y
a Newcastle qui qui sont euh
aussi pareils avec deux matches
en moins. Euh ça c'est un
parcours compliqué donc euh
point de la quatrième point de
la quatrième place, donc c'est
ça qui rajoute le donc moi j'ai
j'ai du mal à croire que que
qu'il qu'ils qu'ils existent
dans cette euh dans cette
rivalité-là. Est-ce que est-ce
que Liverpool pourrait tirer
profit de justement de cette
incertitude qu'il y a autour de
Tottenham euh pour l'instant
encore, qui est donc sans
quatrième mais non plus dans
une très bonne c'est clairement
l'objectif, c'est cette
quatrième place, puisque
Arsenal est devant, Manchester
City juste derrière mais avec
un match en retard ils peuvent
revenir potentiellement à cinq
points, Manon United a deux
matchs en retard donc en fait
la seule place qui reste à
accrocher pour aller en Ligue
des champions c'est la
quatrième donc c'est c'est
Technam, donc c'est l'objectif
de Liverpool, c'est l'objectif
de Newcastle autant que Rémy ou
euh, moi je je pense cette
équipe de Liverpool j'y croyais
avant en milieu de saison,
maintenant j'ai deux voilà
parce que en fait ils sont euh
ils sont capables de faire de
très bons matches mais aussi de
très décevants et euh les
blessés nombreux permettent pas
euh euh et du coup l'entraîneur
est est confronté à ce problème
qui peut on sait que c'est très
compliqué les saisons en
Angleterre il faut amener des
gros effectifs pour faire face
à tous les tous les défis et et
toutes les compétitions où ils
sont engagés et et pour euh
Jogan Klop c'est très compliqué
à gérer cette quelques
pronostics? Téléspectateurs,
Salomon euh CAF, Liverpool ne
va pas bien, la victoire c'est
pour Citizen 4 à un euh ou
alors CAN, Liverpool trois,
Citizen qui joue pas quand même
euh une une partie offensive
qui est qui est qui est très
appuyée sur euh Kevin Dortmund
tu perds quand même à Londres.
Quand même euh voilà il a
combien de buts là? Il est il
est but 4cinq matches
décisives. La machine à
statistiques. C'est efficace
non bien sûr. Ce ce match
ouvrira donc la 20neuvième
journée euh de du championnat
d'Angleterre et dimanche
après-midi rendez-vous à
Manchester United avec
Manchester United qui ira
jouer. Alors ils sont toujours
euh troisièmes hein sur le sur
le podium qui ira jouer à
Newcastle Alors là aussi euh on
a des mancuniens irréguliers,
on a des joueurs, Mike Pierre
aussi euh irréguliers. Euh
Xavier c'est clairement avec
son nouvel investisseur, venu
du golf et tout euh le but est
euh de décrocher la Ligue des
champions. Bien sûr. Et en
début de saison, ils ont été
très accrocheurs, ils ont ils
ont été assez longtemps euh de
troisième et là euh on a
l'impression que ça va moins
fort. Il plafonne un petit peu
parce que c'est une équipe qui
qui pratique quand même un
football assez euh défensif et
donc euh dès qu'il se retrouve
mené au score, ils ont beaucoup
de mal à à revenir et on l'a vu
contre Liverpool par exemple
qui était un match charnière et
à à Saint-James Park devant
leur public et ils ont perdu
deux zéro, ils assez vite mené
au score et ils ont jamais pu
euh revenir. Donc c'est une
équipe qui a qui a une vraie
solidité mais qui est encore
limitée dans son potentiel
offensif, dans son potentiel
créatif. Et c'est très
important pour Newcastle
d'essayer d'accrocher cette
quatrième place parce que s'ils
sont en Ligue des champions,
ils vont arriver à faire venir
ces grands joueurs qui leur
manquent un petit peu,
notamment devant. Mais pour le
moment, euh ça reste quand même
un projet intéressant à suivre.
Hum hum. Eric, vous euh
troubler le le Big Four? Ou pas
encore? C'est c'est c'est
compliqué après euh le le
surtout que c'est tout tout
toutes les équipes qui sont là
euh sont quand même assez
performantes, même si
Manchester United euh euh a
perdu un peu en par rapport à
ce qu'elle a eu mais euh je
reste quand même persuadé que
voilà c'est quand même plus
fort que ouais. Que Newcastle.
Euh Rémy Newcastle ? Hum non.
C'est les nouveaux riches qui
doit attendre encore un spa,
c'est un football horigo. C'est
vrai qu'ils ont actuellement la
meilleure défense avec 16 buts
seulement encaissés. Mais il
faut savoir également que c'est
cette équipe-là lorsque vous
réussissez à déséquilibrer une
fois, eh bien lorsqu'ils
veulent maintenant à la à
l'abordage, tu te rends compte
immédiatement qu'ils n'ont pas
des armes pour pouvoir le
faire. Donc avec peut-être une
ça peut être très compliqué
parce qu'aujourd'hui également
c'est une équipe qui est
devenue assez joueuse et qui
voudrait aussi des points donc
c'est pour ça que je dis que à
ce moment-ci et surtout que on
commence à sentir que ça
commence à tirer sur le plan
physique alors là ça risque
d'être très très compliqué pour
eux par rapport à la débauche
d'énergie. Fred de ces équipes
dont on parle avant le
Manchester euh City Rémy euh
sera euh sera évidemment euh
sur le podium mais euh les euh
donc euh Newcastle euh
Manchester United, Liverpool,
ça fait beaucoup de prétendants
pour euh peu de place dans le
Big Four. Eh oui, il y a que
quatre places hein, on aimerait
bien euh quand on est français,
championnat de France, en avoir
autant hein, quatre places pour
la Ligue des champions, c'est
déjà pas mal. Mais c'est vrai
que Pourquoi il fait? Ce
championnat, à quel niveau,
quand on dit que c'est le
meilleur championnat du monde
euh, c'est pas pour rien hein,
le le championnat anglais
n'oublions pas que on a Chelsea
qui fait une très mauvaise euh
saison en en championnat.
Ouais. Hein, mais les places,
elles se hein mais une année où
Chelsea n'est pas à la hauteur
euh sa bataille euh moi je
pense ça va être quand même
compliqué pour Newcastle il y a
eu un très bon début de saison
ils sont un peu rentrés là dans
le rang bonne faute qui vient
grosse cylindrée euh finissent
très très fort. Il y a des des
inactions. Ils étaient en
finale de la Coupe de la Ligue
si je me souviens bien. Hum
hum. Et c'est Manchester United
qui a gagné. À noter deux
autres rencontres importantes
au cours du week-end si vous
avez envie de de voir des beaux
matchs et il y aura à Naples
euh Naples qui reçoit euh le
mille ans un peu largué hein
parce que ils sont tombés du
podium, ils sont quatrièmes
actuellement. Euh Victor Osimen
ne jouera pas à priori ce
match. Et puis rencontre en
championnat et ensuite c'est le
pré match italien de Naples
hein qui est incroyable comme
ça avec Naples mais vraiment en
sélectionneur suis posé la
question. Il est resté en
Italie ou bien c'est sa
doublure qui était là-bas. Mais
c'était masqué comme Et Et en
France ce sera le Paris
Saint-Germain qui euh essayera
de faire oublier euh ces deux
défaites j'ai oublié. Qui
reçoit dimanche soir ça sera le
match du dimanche soir qui
recevra l'Olympique lunais au
Parc des Princes. Continuons,
parlons football féminin. Annie
la qualification de Bolsburg
les Allemands seront au
rendez-vous des demi-finales,
elles ont réussi à tenir en
échec le Paris Saint-Germain.
Par ici la sortie pour les
clubs euh français, les deux
meilleurs clubs de foot euh
féminin, le Paris Saint-Germain
et puis l'Olympique Lyonnais
ont donc été éliminés euh la
nuit dernière euh c'était en
quart de finale de la Ligue des
championnes, sortie d'une
compétition où pourtant elles
ont l'habitude d'atteindre ce
qu'on appelle euh le dernier
carré, elles y étaient
abonnées, au moins une des
deux, si ce n'est les deux
depuis deux-mille-quatorze,
éliminés donc vous l'avez
entendu par Wolfsburg, qui
retrouvera Arsenal en
demi-finale et qui retrouvera
le Barça, ça sera fin avril. En
tout cas euh Frédéric Suteau
vous avez longtemps euh suivi
ce ce football féminin sur RFI,
est-ce que pour vous c'est la
confirmation, parce qu'on l'a
déjà évoqué euh dans dans Radio
FOOT International, est-ce que
c'est le la concrétisation
d'une mauvaise passe pour les
clubs français? C'est un petit
coup d'arrêt, en tout cas, on
peut pas dire le contraire euh
vous le rappeliez, dernière
fois qu'il y avait pas euh ou
les Parisiennes ou les
Lyonnaises en demi-finale de
CAN c'était en deux-014. Alors
les Lyonnaises, championnes de
romantique elles se font
éliminer aux tirs au but par
Chelsea, elles ont réussi à
renverser la vapeur, bon elles
ont pris un penalty en toute
fin de de prolongation, mais
peu importe le scénario, à
l'arrivée elles ne sont pas là
euh oui c'est c'est un coup
d'arrêt, d'autant plus on on va
en parler que si Lyon a pu
comme ça euh enchaîner les
titres de de championnes
d'Europe pendant des années
hein. Sept euh huit en tout euh
six sur les sept dernières
éditions euh bon c'est aussi
que la concurrence était euh
assez euh bon il y avait euh il
y avait pas grand monde de
l'autre côté alors que là les
les clubs euh anglais
notamment, Arsenal, Chelsea euh
Barcelone bien entendu du
Barcelonaises sont en train à
leur tour de comprendre tout
l'intérêt de développer le foot
féminin, de recruter les
meilleures internationales et
ça devient plus compliqué pour
les Parisiennes, pour les
Lyonnaises. Euh une vraie
concurrence c'est ça. Hum. Bah
après c'est c'est finalement
c'est logique quelque part
puisque il y a il y a un vrai
retour de de de flamme de ces
équipes euh même anglaises qui
qui prennent euh une vraie
investissement. Euh là où on
parlait du Paris Saint-Germain,
l'investissement féminin et et
et moindre par rapport à celui
lyonnais déjà quand on regarde
la comparaison il est moindre
et puis euh et puis là Lyon euh
arrive sur une une euh une
génération qui est en train de
de finir, ça veut dire que
est-ce qu'il y a la relève on
est on est ça va être difficile
de trouver aussi aussi bon euh
euh rapidement si c'est ça a
pas été euh réellement préparé
on continue à s'appuyer sur les
anciennes euh je vois pas
beaucoup de nouvelles joueuses
qui arrivent et qui qui sont
capables de prendre le relais
pour l'instant donc euh ça va
être euh on va surveiller.
Xavier on met en cause les les
le le non seulement euh le le
niveau des équipes voir les
générations, mais il y a aussi
quand même euh euh le ce qui
entoure le football féminin,
c'est-à-dire que les stades où
on fait jouer les filles par
euh parfois et sont pas
forcément de bonne qualité et
notamment les pelouses où elles
disent mais les garçons jouent
pas là-dessus et nous oui euh
c'est c'est considération.
Voilà les infrastructures et
même alors euh l'argent euh
pour euh irriguer les clubs euh
il y a la la retransmission des
matchs euh euh confidentiels.
Euh oui en danger parce qu'ils
sont en fin de compte avec CAN
plus et c'est pas sûr du tout
que le contrat parce que ça
fait pas de de grosses
audiences effectivement. Euh
moi je pense que l'avenir du
football féminin il est dans le
club. C'est-à-dire que les
supporters des équipes
masculines euh vont suivre les
équipes féminines comme ça se
passent au Barça, au Real
Madrid ou à l'Atlético très
intéressante. L'autre fois, on
on se servant du match des
féminines, en levée de rideaux
des de d'un d'un rendez-vous de
de foot masculin. Pas encore.
Le foot féminin encore amateur
il y a peu de temps et il y
avait quelques très bons club
euh problème. Notamment Juvisy
qui a été racheté par le Paris
FOOT euh voilà et donc on veut
pas non plus euh complètement
virer ces clubs amateurs qui
ont beaucoup fait pour le le
football féminin en en les en
raccrochant systématiquement
les sections féminines aux
clubs professionnels de de
Ligue 1 ou de Ligue 2.
Réalisation mais je pense que
malheureusement c'est là où est
l'avenir financier du football
professionnel doivent être mis
un petit peu à la en partie en
tout cas pour le football
féminin et ça passe
effectivement par la
professionnalisation
systématique des des sélections
féminines des clubs. Alors
signe d'alerte euh de de ce
football euh féminin euh
français disons qui ne ne pas
très bien, eh bien c'est le
choix du sélectionneur qui a
été euh officialisé hier, celui
d'Hervé Renard qui va donc
diriger cette équipe de France.
Les Bleues ont en perspective
une coupe du monde dans moins
de 4 mois et dans un an et
demi, les Jeux Olympiques, ce
qui est important au football
féminin, le contrat d'objectif
d'Hervé Renard semble clair. Je
pense que les objectifs sont
assez clairs, il faut dans les
deux compétitions au minimum
rejoindre le dernier carré. Eh
be on m'a demandé très poliment
si vous avez euh l'opportunité
de gagner surtout ne vous en
privez pas. J'ai dit ben merci,
le message est bien reçu mais
je suis venu pour ça. Voilà.
Bon j'aime beaucoup ouais. Hein
le fighting spirit euh de
d'Hervé Renard euh Rémy euh on
l'a beaucoup vu en Afrique là
on le voit au service de
l'équipe de France féminine.
Est-ce que euh selon vous euh
la France qui est au classement
FOOT pour l'instant des nations
un cinquième, est-ce que les
défis qu' où les objectifs
qu'on a mis à Hervé Renard sont
réalistes? Je crois que Hervé
Renard est un grand tacticien.
On a pu le vérifier en Afrique
et puis même euh contre
l'Argentine nous on a vu
jusqu'où il est capable de
pouvoir mettre n'importe quelle
équipe en difficulté. Mais
maintenant, il faut savoir
aussi que est-ce qu'il a la
possibilité de vite
reconstruire quelque chose là?
Parce que quand vous il a fait
appel aux aux cadres,
c'est-à-dire aux anciennes
chômeurs
qui qui ne sont pas en super
forme et qui peut-être même
avec l'élimination, les
éliminations en série d'être
encore quelque chose d'un peu
très terrible par rapport à ce
qui est en train de se passer
en ce moment donc pour moi je
ne pense pas que ça puisse être
à court terme parce que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui travaille
tout de suite à court terme
mais par rapport à l'effectif
qu'il peut avoir, la mise en
place tactique et par rapport à
à qui était contestée, je crois
qu'il peut apporter une
nouvelle chose parce que
l'équipe de France n'avait plus
cette flamme, n'avait plus
cette envie, n'avait plus ce
collectif et bien évidemment
comme le dit un proverbe
africain, on allume pas un
bûcher avec les mains vides.
Donc avec Hervé Renard je crois
moi est-ce qu'il revient avec
quelque chose? Je suis pas
certain que la qualité que
souligne Rémy Gonaud, soit la
première qualité d'Hervé Renard
euh la tactique bon okay, il a
fait jouer ses équipes euh
c'est un véritable bon
communiquant
qui arrive à créer le l'osmose
autour de lui. C'était devenu
clivant, ça ne passait plus
avec on prend le contre-pied.
Un fédéra
teur un un un meneur
d'hommes ou de femmes euh qui
qui effectivement a a en plus
un a priori extrêmement
favorable même si son passé
d'entraîneur professionnel en
France est pas une réussite, il
a pas réussi à sauver
Xavier . Et pas Evian ton
anglais il était à Sochaux
Sochaux contre un rouge. Il
s'était fait chambrer par euh
qui lui a entraîné bientôt. Ils
ont terminé et euh non mais je
je pense que je pense qu'il il
sort un peu de de de je trouve
par rapport au profil de ce
qu'on avait avant, c'est-à-dire
que voilà le le la prise de
risque aussi. Parce que il y a
c'est quand même une prise de
risque. Ce que disait euh il a
pas eu ce qui ce qui mais en
sélection que ce soit en
Afrique ou c'était c'est
certainement beaucoup plus dur
d'aller travailler en Afrique
que de travailler dans un club
avec les avec toutes les
structures et et vous êtes bien
et que c'est je pense que c'est
plus dur d'aller faire des
performances comme il a fait à
la CAN ou euh dans avec des
équipes qui qui où tu les a
seulement de temps en temps. Là
ils est il est il est il est
dans son registre Zambie il est
dans son registre.
Il va devoir euh se créer mais
euh surtout.
Arrive très vite hein, c'est
juillet août euh Australie,
Nouvelle-Zélande et ses
opérations commandos, très
courtes, il a souvent été très
bon euh j'ai bon espoir pour
lui parce que il est il est bon
là-dessus. Vous regardez les
listes pour le moment euh
reviendra, on y reviendra.
Frédéric, est-ce que ça fait
réagir le football féminin euh
est-ce que ça fait réagir?
Alors les messages qui tombent
c'est que la CAN féminine il
est pas très Hervé Renard ne va
rien faire en France.
Un autre
positif il le voulait comme ça
Les filles vont pleurer avec
Hervé Renard
Il y en a d'autres qui sont
malheureux et on va parler
d'eux en quelques instants,
c'est les guépards, les
guépards.
À ce stade, des éliminatoires
pour euh la CAN
deux-mille-vingt-quatre après
quatre journées donc
d'éliminatoire, le Bénin n'a
aucune chance de disputer cette
compétition euh africaine à
moins évidemment d'un miracle.
Dans leur groupe, elles, faut
dire que c'est pas simple hein,
il y a le Sénégal dans ce
groupe, donc déjà euh c'est un
peu euh compliqué et puis il y
a aussi le Mozambique qui a
pris euh un bon départ et le
Rwanda est aussi devant. Les
Néo-Gépards sont derniers avec
seulement deux points. Mais le
Bénin se sent lésé car la
double confrontation a été
parasitée par Dunk décision de
la CAF au grand dam de or, le
sélectionneur Euh la CAF nous a
fait souffrir beaucoup déjà
avant ce match avec les
va-et-vient. Et là on a
constaté qu'elle n'a même pas
suspendu un joueur qui a eu
deux cartons. Donc nous l'avons
signalé au commissaire de
match. Je pense que la justice
sportive demande que s'assoit
sanctionner et vous connaissez
les sanctions. Alors les deux
matches auraient donc dû se
disputer à Cotonou sur décision
de la CAF parce que le stade
n'était pas homologué,
finalement ils ont quand même
joué non pas dans le stade
initial mais euh à Kigali et
puis un international rwandais
n'aurait jamais dû faire le
match et là il y a un problème
de euh euh rapport d'arbitrage
euh et tout ça. Mais
théoriquement objectivement la
le on on peut se dire ça ne
peut être qu'en faveur du Bénin
pourtant euh Eric? Ben ça
devrait mais ça ça ne saura pas
je pense sincèrement. J'ai
malheureusement j'ai envie de
dire à Yann n'espère pas grand
chose puisque ils ont déjà été
lésés Le Bénin avec euh
l'histoire de la RDC entre le
le nombre de changements qu'il
y avait eu et que pour les
éliminatoires de la Coupe du
monde, où il y a eu, c'était
énorme, tellement énorme. Entre
le le le le le le il y avait
une euh une de trop. De trop.
Non, il y avait 4 périodes de
l'histoire avec rien du tout.
Sierra Réaliste. Enchaîne et
accumule, c'est c'est c'est
c'est cette frustration donc je
je comprends le la la démarche
mais je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
qu'il soit à la fin. Ils sont
un peu les boucs émissaires en
Afrique euh malheureusement
c'est un petit pays et ils ont
eu beau changer les écureuils
en en guépard, ils se font non
mais c'est vrai, ils se font
encore voler match. C'est c'est
vraiment désespérant pour eux.
Euh Éric le rappelait,
l'histoire euh je commentais ce
match contre la RDC ou
l'entraîneur euh des léopards
fait quatre, quatre périodes de
changement. C'est incroyable.
C'est c'est c'est tout à fait
irrégulier. Eh ben il passe
quand même en et le Bénin est
éliminé euh irrégulièrement,
contre euh pour la CAN pareil.
Là, alors l'histoire des
changements de stade encore,
mais du coup
pays
à Kigali. Bon, on passe encore.
Mais du coup, il a lieu quand?
Il a lieu le mercredi on se
retrouve avec trois joueurs qui
rentrent euh dans leur club.
Rémy franchement ça fait mal au
coeur pour eux. Est-ce que ça
vous étonne Rémy est-ce que
vous pensez que que le Bénin
euh va pouvoir euh trouver des
alliés qui vont les aider? Je
crois que nous n'allons pas
d'abord parler seulement d'un
problème concernant le Bénin
parce que si c'est le sujet?
Non non non mais ça existe les
salut
Ben le Bénin peut pas avoir
lieu
Tanzanie on a vu un match bien
évidemment où l'arbitre euh a
eu à mettre par exemple hum
trente-six minutes de temps
additionnel parce qu'il y a eu
coupure d'électricité pour ça.
Mais on n'est pas revenu sur
ça, la CAF est souvent habituée
à ça par rapport à des à des
fautes de règlement, c'est ça
le pire. C'est pour ça que
l'arbitrage parle de
ou bien qu'on a quelque chose
contre le Bénin. Je crois que
non non non cela veut dire tout
simplement que vous ne suivez
pas l'évolution du football
Afrique parce que justement
allons je vous demande mais
Mais c'est peut-être le c'est
peut-être le Rwanda qui est en
coulisse à beaucoup de de
pouvoir. De la FIFA organisé à
Kigali Laissons aussi ça, je
vais vous dire une chose. Que
le dix-neuf en 209, je je je
résume pour que nos amis bénins
ne se cachent pas par quoi sur
certaines incompétences. Parce
que je dis bien que au Bénin,
moi j'ai vu l'équipe du Bénin
face au Togo, des Bayern
qualifiés pour la CAN en 2019
et ils sont arrivés à la CAN
2019 dans la dans le même
groupe que le Cameroun. Ils ont
tenu le Cameroun en échec, ils
ont battu le Maroc qui est une
grande nation de football. Et
ils sont éliminés. Ils sont
allés en quart de finale. Ils
sont allés en quart de finale.
Et pourquoi est-ce que ils ont
réussi à éliminer le Maroc qui
est une grande nation de
football? Moi je m'attendais à
ce que le Bénin évolue. Or le
Bénin pendant que le Maroc
évolue va à la coupe du monde,
va en demi-finale lui il recule
eh on change les écuries ça
devient guépard après cela
après ce sera j'ai dit ceci
pour l'instant le football
béninois n'a pas évolué et elle
doit s'apprendre d'abord à
eux-mêmes parce que si ils sont
là aujourd'hui seulement pour
les arbitres non je dois être
honnête là je l'ai remis sauf
que toi tu parles de football
là mais là on parle pas de
football on parle de règlement
qui est bafoué par rapport à à
un comportement de de la CAF et
tout ça c'est ça le problème,
c'est pas le problème de
football là. C'est pas le
problème de l'évolution
technique ou euh ou entraîneur
ou de ou de tout le football du
problème que tu fais des
règlements. J'ai d'abord évoqué
le problème de la CAF que par
exemple pour pays on voit
trente-six-mille avec le
Cameroun, avec des tests comme
à gauche et à droite, il y a
toujours toutes ces mais ce
n'est pas contre la non, mais
c'est pas contre le Bénin,
c'est pas ça qu'on dit. Bon ça
tombait souvent sur euh sur le
le le le sort du Bénin. Euh
Frédéric, il y a quelques
commentaires au sujet? Ouin on
nous parle de prière, vaudou
euh et à Constant Guy qui nous
dit la CAF c'est du désordre
euh permanent. C'est terrible.
Euh Alexandre Ezechiel, le
Bénin ferait mieux de se
concentrer sur les valises
magiques
Ça c'est le mauvais conseil, on
le dit clairement. Nous on
accompagne le message mais
c'est le mauvais conseil. Bon
on espère bonne chance en tout
cas aux écureuils ou au guépard
euh qui quelque soit leur nom
et à Guerre Notre euh bon
courage euh à eux aussi pour ce
qui va se passer euh dans les
recours et les arcanes de la
confédération africaine de
football. On continue et on
arrive à la session que je suis
sûre vous adorez tous, les
cartons. Carton jaune! Un
carton jaune oh là là là là!
Carton rouge! Carton rouge!
Dans la conclusion. Carton vert
les cartons envoyés par nos
fidèles auditeurs euh
internautes et sélectionnés par
Victor Missistrano et Pierre
Guérin et vous allez voir
Espérance elle est encore là.
Bonsoir la grande famille
madame Annie Xavier Barret
c'est Adama Diabaté depuis la
Guinée Konari dans la région
forestée précisément à Lola et
comme ma région je donne un
carton vert euh aussi national
plus précisément aux U
vingt-trois pour les
qualifications pour la première
fois j'ai Salut salut Radio
FOOT . . . . . . Carton vert
aux Aigles I 23 du Mali pour
leur brillante qualification à
la crème divers catégories. Ils
avaient perdu la manche aller à
Dakar par trois vies bizarres.
Au retour à Bamako ils ont
livré une performance X XL en
l'emportant par trois B à zéro.
Salut Radio FOOT International
CAN depuis les EA, double
carton vers le accordé à
l'équipe U23 de la Guinée pour
leur qualification à leur
catégorie. Et le second pour
ses prestations XXL avec
l'équipe de France. Ciao.
International. C'est ma
dernière depuis le Sénégal. Euh
carton rouge à la fédération
sénégalaise de football et à la
direction technique nationale.
Parce que ils n'ont pas pu
aider l'équipe olympique en
sélectionneur notre capitaine
qui nous a manqué un match
retour au Mali. Donc ça nous a
privé une qualification à la
CAN et de
CAN Ronaldo pour sa nouvelle
master class malgré son âge il
porte encore le Portugal avec
un doublé il est tout
simplement un extraterrestre.
Bonjour à tous bonjour Radio
FOOT International, je suis
Honoré, Togolais, vivant en
Italie. Je donne un carton vert
à Eve Rina pour sa nomination à
la tête de l'équipe de football
féminin. Bon vent à lui dans sa
nouvelle mission. Bonjour euh
Rémy bonjour depuis Kinshasa.
Mon carton est vert. Vert
adressé à monsieur Les Sables
par rapport à un travail qu'il
est en train de faire avec euh
la sélection nationale de la
RDC qui c'est pourquoi je je
lui adresse vraiment un carton
vert pour son travail. Salut à
tous international, moi c'est
So Amadou depuis Brazzaville au
Congo. Alors mon carton du jour
il est rouge, rouge comme on a
vila, elle est pour l'album qui
a sifflé le match contre la
RDC, vraiment dommage à
l'arbitrage. Bonjour radio FOOT
International, c'est Espérance
Loutaya congolaise de
Brazzaville depuis le Ghana.
Aujourd'hui, mon carton il est
rouge et je l'attribue au pays
de Rémy Mono, précisément du
Cameroun. Le Cameroun s'est
incliné deux buts à un face à
la Namibie, un match de
qualification pour la CAN.
Malheureusement, comme le dit
un proverbe africain, la piqûre
d'un moustique peut bien tuer
un gorille. Cette merveilleuse
équipe camerounaise qu'on a
tous connue n'est plus la même
aujourd'hui. C'est dommage.
Salut Radio FOOT c'est depuis
Sénégal. Je donne un carton
vert à Reiming Gono, Rémy Ngono
est un zéni. Rémy Gon est un
vrai vrai ennemi. Il a évalué
la performance des deux
gardiens pour remplacer André
Ona dans la sélection
camerounaise. Mais ces gardiens
ne sont pas des vrais
remplaçants pour on en a. Masse
nul à Yaoundé et bien pour
cette masse. Alors fais tout
que on en revient dans cette
sélection. On verra Rémy vous
avez du travail aussi euh faire
attention aux moustiques. Parce
que apparemment c'est dangereux
les moustiques. Euh Frédéric
Suteau votre carton, à vous la
parole. Il est rouge, carton
rouge au consulat général de
France à Libreville. Au Gabon,
on a les jeunes Gabonais, les
moins de 16 ans, qui devaient
venir jouer là à partir de
dimanche, le tournoi de
Montaigu en en France, qui fait
figure de de championnat du
monde des des moins de 16 ans.
Vous avez des meilleures euh
équipes de jeunes du du monde.
Les Gabonais devaient venir, le
consulat général de France ne
leur a pas donné de visa euh
sous prétexte euh que il
pouvait disparaître dans la
nature et profiter euh de ce
tournoi pour ne pas revenir au
pays. Bon, ça a fait beau de
bruit. Euh on en a parlé sur
RFI, sur France 24. Euh un peu
embarrassé le consulat a fini
par donner euh le visa mais
trop tard, l'avion est parti
euh et donc euh rate le
tournoi. Vraiment c'est pas
glorieux organisé en France par
la France et c'est très connu
euh je crois que Pierre Guérin
disait que c'est depuis
mille-neuf-cent-soixante-treize
si je me trompe pas ce tournoi
non aigu. Hum Eric euh moi
c'est pareil que le le
l'auditeur tout à l'heure c'est
euh Hervé Renard euh
la fédé française, j'ai envie
de dire. Parce que le choix est
quand même euh est quand même
pertinent par rapport aux
besoins de cette équipe de de
de de France féminine et
surtout besoin de lumière.
Aussi aussi au timing
c'est-à-dire que voilà on a
vraiment besoin de voilà de
quelqu'un qui va être capable
de de fédérer, de réveiller un
petit peu ces filles qui sont
talentueuses mais qui manquent
peut-être de de. D'un guide.
Voilà. Rémy alors carton jaune
euh une star du Gabon qui est
devenue une histoire, une
étoile sombre à savoir Pierre
Meïk, Aubameyang qui était
parti de sélection
sélectionneur
avec parce qu'il faisait la
bamboula pendant que les autres
jouaient au foot et cette
fois-ci il a l'occasion de
revenir en sélection lui ouvre
les portes et il fait la fine
bouche comme s'il ne voulait
pas venir et pourtant quand il
partait c'était pour briller en
club. Et qu'est-ce qu'on a vu
pratiquement? Il est dans
l'obscurité et avec Chelsea il
a joué que cette petite minute
Pierre on te voit plus là-bas
tu es fini. Repars dans ton
pays où tu es star car il y a
un proverbe africain qui dit
clairement ceci l'enfant qui se
chauffe au feu de bois dans la
cuisine de sa mère ne mourra
jamais de famine. C'est joli.
Xavier a vous. Couleur. Très
gentil aujourd'hui hein. Oui
mais jaune c'est ça un simple
avertissement. Avertissement
aux sélection de France des
jeunes qui ont joué lors de
cette phase euh un certain
nombre de match euh et qui ont
eu résultats assez médiocres
voire carrément décevants, les
U dix-neuf par exemple. Et dans
un moins de 9 ans, dans un tour
qualificatif pour l'euro des 19
ans, euh il jouait contre
l'Irlande du Nord, la Norvège
et la Roumanie avec Mattiste du
Bayern de Munich, Désiré Doué
de Rennes. Euh Eliane oui
Waren Zaïre Emery du Paris
Saint-Germain? Il y avait du eh
ben ils se sont fait éliminer.
Non. Ils se sont fait éliminer
de l'Euro dès 19 ils iront pas
à la phase finale, malgré tous
ces quand vous avez autant
performants quand même. Mais
oui, en moins de vingt, en
moins de vingt, ils préparent
la coupe du monde qui aura pas
lieu en Indonésie, on sait pas
où elle aura lieu. Ils ont ils
ont ils ont un nul, une
victoire, une défaite, et les
espoirs ils ont pris quatre
zéro contre les Anglais alors
qu'ils préparent l'Euro espoir.
Franchement jaune les gars,
reprenez-vous. Est-ce que que
jaune? Alors le carton de Radio
FOOT international est rouge et
il va justement dans la suite
de ce que vous avez dit à deux
gouverneurs d'Indonésie, ceux
qui gouvernent euh euh Bali et
ceux qui gouvernent Java parce
qu'ils sont à l'origine de la
décision de la FIFA justement
de désaisir l'Indonésie de
l'organisation de cette Coupe
du monde euh de des moins de 20
ans alors euh ces deux
gouverneurs voulaient interdire
la participation d'Israël une
équipe qui s'est qualifiée sur
le terrain mais surtout les les
jeunes de moins de vingt qui se
préparaient à cette
compétition, qui se préparaient
à la disputer à la maison euh
était en pleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que si le pays la
la compétition est attribuée à
quelqu'un d'autre, il
semblerait que ce soit
l'Argentine, eh ben ils seront
peut-être pas euh qualifiés
d'office. Ça sera l'Argentine
qui n'est pas qualifiée et qui
pourrait récupérer la place.
C'est très triste. Ouais. Mais
c'est la fin de ce café des
sports avec le sourire. On vous
souhaite un excellent week-end,
n'est-ce pas? On est tous
d'accord. Excellent week-end à
tous et merci, on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine.